my name is concealed and professionally
right now I'm busy making the world
better by making everyone in it laughs I
grew up not knowing that anyone can be
funny and you're like the only funny
person is mr. bean till I came to the
city at the University and then you
realize that people there's so much
attention whenever you open your mouth
to speak you're trying to be serious and
people are laughing
it was difficult like any other job but
I don't want to claim that we want a
disadvantage if anything entering that
the comedy industry as women was an
advantage cause men badly wanted that
the female touch there's a skit I did
about condoms
my husband was travelling and he and I
told him oh you need condoms you never
know you know there's so much temptation
out there you might be tempted so just
carry the condoms I trust you I just
don't trust that people you're going to
meet he's like oh my god you're so kind
I'm like wait hold on I've given you all
of them just in me too in case that
Shambo is going to come what any in case
there's temptation I can also use the in
Kenya the same can see me is promoting
promiscuity what does that be bad radio
debates and they were like no it's
actually not promoting promiscuity what
she's doing is telling you it happens
protect yourself
I think the fact that I act about a day
to day scenarios
I believe in changing words I'm changing
words and if they have a purpose is
something I know whatever it is I do
eventually effects